on me dit que c'est une question pour
agathe on a un magnéto a priori c'est
sur votre embrouille agathe avec
benjamin castaldi et avec matthieu
delormeau voilà à gâteau proulx après la
brouille as-tu pensé à partir de tpm p
on va revoir cet extrait vous allez nous
dire toute la vérité après regardez je
trouve que on a raconté mais des
inepties inepties sur l'ineptie entre
benjamin castaldi
excuse moi qui relaie des faits que nous
la fachosphère en prêtant si en prêtant
une proximité
tu va retirer tout de suite en prêtant
longue date ont tué quand je te demande
pas là
maintenant c'est vrai que j'ai eu ma
dose de jus de malesherbes hors de moi
les mêmes si c'est toi qui les a dit et
tu dis que tu es tu es tu as été victime
de twitter tu n'es pas victime des
réseaux sociaux
tu étais coupable toi à l'époque sur les
réseaux sociaux en sortant en plus ils
jamais dit j'avais moi je te le dis en
sortant on s'entend en plus large des
scud de l'âge qui est ridicule là sauf
que tu dis en défendant cette jeune
fille que tu l'a fait hier toi même tu
as fait l'apologie d'horreur aller très
vite bac l année c'est ce que tu dis que
tu ne m'avais un shérif s'épanouit sous
prétexte qu'on est jeunes on peut écrire
tout et n'importe quoi alors c'est quoi
tes élise lucet de tpm p est ce que tu
as fait vraiment une enquête non soit et
des éléments soient tap tap a des
éléments mais c'est trop grave si tu
veux pour dire un truc comme ça alors
vous a vu à la fin on voit pas d'où vous
l'avez pas partir à vous dites je n'ai
pas d'amis dans tpm p1 voilà ça on verra
ce qui est notre question paraît-il
dessus
agathe est ce que vous avez pensé partir
de ce que pettitte la vérité hellmuth
vous regarde et les téléspectateurs
aussi que j'ai je suis partie du plateau
déjà j'ai quitté cette émission après la
la la séquence moi justement on a le
montage où elle part ou pas rampant bah
voilà ils ont tout pris souffle au
tournant par l'origine il comme de
l'ibère du plateau je peux perdre pour
être précis ouais alors à garder parce
qu'elle n'est pas ce qu'on me dit dans
l'oreillette que je suis pas très bien
et il me propose gentiment de partir et
je l'en remercie évidemment donc sur la
phase 1 chez je me suis mal exprimé
envers benjamin notamment sur la phase 2
elle était complètement inutile en fait
j'ai pas compris pourquoi on revenait
dessus
non mais la question est claire
justement partir de tmp oui ou non non
non papa non vraiment vous êtes dit je
vais revenir
ouais et surtout vous me connaissez un
peu je suis très très entière un petit
peu impulsive de l'élégance qui se passe
chose dans cette émission autour de
cette émission me déplaît je vous le dis
immédiatement et après cette phase là on
s'est beaucoup parlé par sms comme comme
avec géraldine aussi qui m'a écrit et je
vous ai jamais exprimé l' envie de
partir après ça
voilà franchement je croyais que vous
aviez envie de partir quand même elle
monte elle ment je pense qu'il ya les
deux là un combat interne d'un côté dit
j'ai envie de partir de l'autre côté a
sa raison qui a dit non tu restes et
s'est battu avec elle même et donc
qu'elle a menti elle a dit la vérité en
même temps il est bon sur la toile
si vous le reconnaissez elle travaille
pour monture lice à bercy